he's already been to the line seven  times and he's six for seven  and he was coming  [Applause]  hard and fast right at eight and mark  you made the  uh point aidan's gotta square his body  up  he's got his shoulder trying to absorb  the contact  he's got to get his chest in there  three fouls on eight already  14th house for phoenix we're not even  four minutes in  [Applause]  the free throws look good tonight he's  had stretches during the season during  the regular season where he shot the  free throw so well  here's what you were talking about  earlier mark  it's incredible how many pounds he's put  on obviously he's grown a little bit but  since he was he's grown  seven inches  [Applause]  believe it or not giannis once had a  game where he shot  17-17 from the free-throw line  when was that mike a couple of years ago  that's incredible i mean what  what's impacted it so negatively yes  milwaukee regains the lead and the crowd  on its feet